yes sir it's mario and you checking out
the homie bootleg cab right here on this
podcast i see what's going on black
table all black everything black mike
let's go
bullet cab show special guest in here my
guy the legend my guy what's good mario
yes sir welcome how you been i've been
great bro long time it's been a minute
yeah uh you got this new record out with
chris which is crazy get back to you bro
appreciate you um what like what's been
going on in your world though man for
people who ain't been paying attention
man
um
a lot man of course the singles out
right now
you know we just want to do something
iconic for r b you know we're working on
shooting a video getting that all the
way right
setting up the summer time i got a
couple other singles coming really just
focusing on singles for this summer you
know what i'm saying and then
project probably end of the year top of
next year sometime
um but [ __ ] my world bro i've been
creating a lot creating a lot writing
writing a book right now
um working on some other business
is the book kind of like your your life
story nah it's not really a life story
it's more of like a a memoir it's more
of like a
balancing your personal spiritual space
conversation you know this conversation
i'm having with myself that that
i'm kind of bringing the world into you
know i feel like i've been in the
industry so long and i've also just been
through a lot of different things in
different dimensions of my life i needed
an outlet you know it's kind of like
therapy therapy in a way you know um
so it promotes mental health it promotes
spiritual awareness it promotes
um
social awareness
you know it's it's got a little bit of
everything in there you have had a
pretty wild ride through just life when
we think about things that have happened
in your personal life your career has
always it's got peaks and valleys and
you know anytime you're a creator and
you're under the
microscope it it feels like you know
sometimes we forget that like
you're a human being
and yeah
you know
it's
you have to train yourself it's like you
know as you as you get older i started
so young but as you get older i think
you get these pockets of like
um
growth spurts of
spiritual intelligence emotional
intelligence and those are the things
that you need to tap into
if you're not distracted enough too much
by
the lifestyle you know and i always i've
always been aware of that i mean i had
my moments where i was super distracted
by it but like for the most part i've
always been so i'm self-aware just
because of where i grew up you know what
i'm saying i seen all the craziest stuff
in my life earlier on so this was just
kind of like okay this is more like uh
human
behavior
you know
psychological
um energetic how do you navigate that
that's what i feel like the industry is
more so you talk about mental health
like yeah um
how like because you've like i said
you've been you've dealt with
stuff that a lot of people haven't had
to deal with in their life um
even
and as a star
you know what i mean which is what's
even crazier
people deal with certain [ __ ] no one
knows who the [ __ ] they are you're
dealing with a lot of [ __ ] you know when
it comes to what happened with your mom
you know um moving back to baltimore
when you were already on yeah you know
what i mean like
do you feel like um
you know i think sometimes we we look at
artists and we're like
you know if if we think of mario we're
like okay what's mario been up to do you
feel like you've had to like kind of
battle through any like personal
depression or anything to kind of break
through like to where you are today
um
what we what we call depression
i mean this is just like my perspective
but what we call depression and you know
um stress and
um just those immense deep moments of
like where you feel like your life is
over the world is over is triggers for
us to work on things that are unhealed
um
that we're not walking a path that's
true to our
purpose sometimes you know what i mean
so for me
it was like i had moments of depression
but i didn't sit in them too long i more
so spent more time just studying and
understanding
um my history understanding
you know my purpose outside of just
music and it just gave me more more of a
of a purpose and foundation when it
comes to me as a human being and that
helps with everything else once i
figured that part out and luckily i
started young enough to wear those five
six years where i was just like
not really
doing the music thing and just kind of
focusing on myself
luckily i started so young you know
because now it's like i have all of that
knowledge to kind of like apply to you
right now yeah i was gonna say
everything bro do you think starting um
kind of having to be forced to grow up
fast right yeah um do you think that
that kind of helped prepare you for life
like you know had maybe you gone through
some of the things you went through at
18 or 19 years old without having to
have been kind of a superstar and you
know be mario do you think that kind of
helped prepare you for some of the
things you did go through later on
i think um
like i said before just coming from
baltimore being exposed to so much at a
young age like
you know
being in a house full of 18 with 18
people as uncles cousins
moms boyfriends aunties like it was just
you know it was one of those houses like
when we lived in emerson village it was
like
you remember that scene on uh
minister society and beginning to open
the scene
i wouldn't say
kids was exposed all the way but it was
it was close to that like you know what
i'm saying we didn't know what was going
on but we knew you know what i'm saying
so
being that i saw so much and i was
exposed to so much i had already been
prepared mentally for
uh inconsistencies in dealing with
things and dealing with people dealing
with certain and so i didn't
as i got older i didn't know like like
attach it to a reality
it was like okay this is my reality and
the reality of the space that i'm in is
this this and that like you know what
i'm saying so you have a house full of
18 people you grow up in in baltimore
shout out to baltimore by the way total
coincidence i'm wearing a wire t-shirt i
see uh wrestling piece of the rest in
peace uh but uh
you get on as a teenager yeah i mean
you're like super on you're like running
106 in park like
you're like the next r b sensation
do
the house full of 18 people start
looking for you to like start handling
some some things as far as bills or was
it was it not never like that nah it
wasn't like that bro like my family was
very supportive
um i left baltimore for like four years
when i was like 14. you know what i'm
saying so it was more about who'd you go
uh to jersey okay okay i'm saying and so
it was more about
like um
it was it was more about like
missing my family and just like them i
unders like that transition between me
being just mario but like and mario the
artist like you know what i'm saying it
wasn't like like that later on it kind
of in some cases but like it was my
family was never like like that my
family was always supportive you know my
family is real like real people like you
know what i'm saying right yeah
um you talk about how you took like a
four or five year break from music uh as
far as like just having that be like
your main focus yeah um
i always think it's like you as somebody
who doesn't get enough flowers for just
kind of like your legacy like some of
the records you've put out some of the
bodies of work you've had and like just
in general
do you feel like that four to five years
was necessary even though it might have
maybe hurt your place in the game
yeah definitely it was necessary for me
it was necessary for
my personal growth again
um it was also necessary for me to like
not
attack like attach my value to
[Music]
success
or whatever success is perceived to be
by people you know for me i redefined
what success was for me so success for
me was a healthy mind a healthy spirit
you know what i'm saying success is very
subjective man longevity bro let let's
be let's keep it 100 like
we we live you know these lives you know
we have 24 hours in a day
you know um when you become an artist
there's so many other things that people
don't realize the responsibilities and
the stress that come with being an
artist like it really can take a toll on
you so if you're not like preparing
yourself for the next 10 years
then i don't think like for me i feel
like artists have to learn how to
prepare themselves for the next 10 15
years like what's your retirement plan
like you feel me because like
you know this [ __ ]
music come and go i've been blessed
enough to come out in a time where like
music was really about classics you know
what i'm saying this is true people like
yo
when you oh you're making a comeback
it's like nah it's not really a comeback
let me love you streams
two million times every day and a half
that's so crazy you feel me how do i
breathe straight like my hits still go
crazy for sure as if they just came out
so it's like for me it's just more of a
rebranding thing than it is a coming
back thing yeah i think like you said
man i think like when we think of
success like success is defined to
everyone's personal
like happiness yeah like for sure
you know i think that there's like if
you if you're
if you're um
in the industry and you're known for
being an artist there is definitely
um
certain milestones certain milestones
are certain things that comes with like
somebody can
view your success as an artist in terms
of the numbers in terms of like this
there's no you know but in terms of like
personal success that's that's something
that you
have to that has to be your own personal
virtue you know what i'm saying but um
i think that success comes with
happiness comes with success to me it's
like if i'm not happy
whether it's a relationship a business
um
working partnership like if we're not
enjoying the process of this and i think
depending make sure that's all that like
yo are you enjoying what you do like who
are you really outside of just what the
world knows you for or your public
perception a lot of that [ __ ] went away
during the week yeah you know so so
success
has to go for me true success has to run
hand in hand with happiness and and
peace
and um enjoying what you're doing and
enjoying the process whether you're
making money or are you are you enjoying
what you do why are you making this
bread like you know what i'm saying 100
man um
so music wise now you obviously put the
new record out with chris which is dope
to see you guys on a shout out to the
homie because you guys kind of had like
you guys kind of from the same era a bit
right yeah i came out a few years before
yeah let's say you came out first but
like you know kind of you know similar
eras like um i feel like would also he
is crazy because the first time i ever
seen him he came out on tour i was on
tour with a beast beyonce
and he came out on stage and did i think
he did run it that sounds about right
and i was like yo this kid is out of
here yeah he's a superstar like it was
just which beyonce tour was that it was
destiny shout out to it i forgot the
name of it but it was so you were on
tour with destiny's child world tour in
the world so it was crazy i had to be
wild as wow bro
this is before beyonce went solo every
every continent basically this is pre
beyonce going solo pretty crazy in love
yeah oh wow yeah that was like that was
a special time people forgetting
destiny's child like as a group and like
how crazy they were like it was they had
a lot of hits and they had a lot their
fan base was just versatile and just you
know i think they came out of town with
like girl groups and groups in general
was still like you know popping in and
it was it was important to the culture
they were kind of like the last great
female group if we really think about it
like when was like the last time there's
been an amazing like female r b group
that really like i can't really think of
one bro like that
i feel like they were the last of their
they were kind you know
and even r b groups in general and
that's who everybody kind of branched
off and did their own thing and put out
like actual independent projects that
had success too you know i just think of
like you know when i was a kid it was
like drew hill there was jagged edge and
there's 112 and like now i i don't like
is there an r b group that i'm
forgetting that i'm just like i feel
like it's been so many like on and off
but not as far as girl groups i can't
remember any did you kind of did
everyone kind of know when you were
around destiny's child back then that
beyonce was like you know okay there's
something special about of course like
you know she's
of course yeah yeah i'm saying she's a
superstar she's a virgo like me hey
shout out to the verb said virgos do the
best
michael jackson
a lot of great nah i think i think it
all goes back to work ethic bro like she
was
she was trained and bred for it you know
from
from a young age you know think about
michael like he was trained and brave
for it you know what you focus your
attention and awareness on it's gonna
continue to
to to magnify you know what i'm saying
and be more magnetic so in polarizing so
you know it's crazy because i think when
i think of bt and 106 and park i think
you i think a bow wow
i think of a few artists do you remember
the first time you went on 1016 park
and like who was hosting yeah aj and
free was hosting that's the see that's
the og's like aj and free is like that's
how i remember 106 in park i sure there
were so many other you know incarnations
of the host of the show but aj and three
were the ones those are the original you
know the original matters and in the in
the whole team over there like i see
some of them still on different
production sets movie sets war shows you
know eight bites still it's crazy you
see people aj's on like entertainment
tonight at least he was like i'd be like
entertainment tonight was i'm like yes
[ __ ] aj from 16th park i don't watch
a lot of tv show i wouldn't know but
yeah aj always was doing his thing yeah
no that's crazy man yeah that's do you
remember how many times you actually
ended up going because you know you were
on there a lot um
i can't remember offhand but like i
would say
probably at least like 10 times or more
that's huge
ten times that was that man missed those
shows i think i think we definitely
gotta bring something like that back i
think the culture would miss i think
youtube kind of killed
the video show if that makes sense
because i think they've tried to bring
back trl before and it just didn't i
just think i think i think the digital
crusade in general did it yeah like it's
like so there's so many people creating
their own podcast their own this their
own that that is like it's just
something where they want to get there
it's it's a different um
it's definitely just everything's just
different like i'm working on something
crazy
um
in that space kind of but bigger right
now i can't talk about it all the way
but yeah it's gonna be it's gonna be
super crazy like i'm working on some
cool stuff
would you ever do um like a show like
the mass singer if they asked you
yeah
i'll do that for fun for sure do they yo
the master has been kind of lit low-key
i do that for fun it's like certain
people like uh whiz was on there
i want to say tiger was on there
obviously the tiger did it did he that's
crazy t-pain one yeah
one
uh
yeah tyreese did it yeah i would
definitely do it that'd be crazy because
i think is it i think it's
because i i would be able to show people
like the other side of my voice the
other textures and tones that i have
because it's like r b is like
i haven't even people haven't even
touched like seen or experienced like
the magnitude of where i can go vocally
so that's definitely one that i would do
like how do you feel about the current
state of r b because it's definitely a
lot different than 10 15 years ago as
far as just like you know i feel like i
feel like
r b has changed so much even just like
you know we talked about the digital era
i feel like artists are so
like they have to be more transparent
now as to where maybe when
you know i was a kid and you were a kid
you know every r b artist had this like
image
right they were like sex symbols and
they had it it was very polished it was
very polished very popular nowadays it's
like you could just be a normal dude
yeah and like the fans almost like that
more now yes i think it's getting back
to
no point it's in it it's getting back to
the rawness
and connecting with your fans and
connecting with people and and jamming
you know what i'm saying jam sessions
getting back to just
you know
working with people that
you vibe with on a creative level and
making music that you love and hopefully
having a label that supports that do you
like do you like this now i think the
hardest part about it is
finding
a machine that's willing to
get behind even if it's
independent because independents are now
like the new labels like you know what
i'm saying like the process you know
what i'm saying of course getting them
to also believe in like
because there's so much in the
marketplace you know so r b tends to
take longer to build you know um unless
you're just one of those phenomenons
like a russ who like figure out how to
you know do you well you know connect
with your fans well yeah well
what russ did is what i just advise a
lot of artists to do is like just keep
putting up shots especially if you're
independent
yes but you gotta understand there's a
psychological part
that comes with that and sorry i'm
moving around a lot just like a very
like it's it's a psychological part that
comes with doing that like
when you're when you're
trained to
okay one single hair and then album like
you gotta like retrain yourself i've
been retraining myself because you're
thinking like okay i got a song we gotta
make sure there's a budget behind it the
video bro the virgo like i think so
meticulously my team they'd be like bro
you overthink i'm very like
the colors that this gotta master the
even when i did my independent project i
was shooting my videos i was doing i was
so meticulous versus just
throwing out music and just seeing with
stick you know what i'm saying so i'm
training myself to kind of find a
balance between being overly creative
and like
you know
everything's got to be perfect to just
yo do what you love i feed your fans are
you currently independent yeah okay yeah
that's a good place i got a partnership
so me uh
um dre london shout out to dre yeah
great guy he's a maniac i've known that
for very long shout out to my manager
andy you know we you know we just we
partnered and we we got a lot of great
things on the way you know i think it's
done a really good job of being like
kind of like a traditional r b artist
but also
adapting to
the way people consume music as eric
bellinger yeah because eric has has so
much shout out to eb he's got so much
catalog yeah i mean he's putting out two
albums a year yeah and i think that's
smart for him though i think he's i
think i think it's very it's very like
you know
he's like one of the guys who i see
who's like a traditional
r b artist that could have existed in
2003 for sure
and has figured out kind of like how to
do it independently in a way that like
you know
just keep putting up put he's just
feeding his fan base you know for sure
that's that's the i think like for
artists who came out and in this
particular era i think it's smart
um
for me it's more about like
still making classic records even if
it's
you know it's like it's like it still
has to have a certain
energy and vibe to it to where as though
it stands out from everything else you
know what i'm saying i'm not just like
throwing anything against the against
the board i don't have it in me to do
that but i definitely
will say to the fans out there watching
say the people out there like
this is probably going to be the most
music but within this next two years
that i've put out in a long time that's
especially quality music
have you uh you know what was dope about
uh the pandemic is we got all these
versus battles yeah and the scott storch
one you know he had to bust out that let
me love you yes sir remind people uh
spit up baby jew and storch get back i
mean storch is super active right now
he's he's he's he's doing this common
thing we we definitely we ramp it up
we've been chopping it up so it's always
it's always a time and an energy thing
it's gonna be crazy i actually got a
record that i want him to do some
production on it's already written he's
fired got a feature on the fire but i
just hear his
touch man he's scott is one of the most
prolific producers um he really
understands musicality and he just
he gets it bro he's talented you can't
take it during the let me love you eric
did you like ever go party with him when
he was like on his like you know what do
you mean
of course this is like legendary guy and
his the party stories are crazy listen
this is this is my introduce me to miami
oh okay i'll kill you scott introduced
me to miami like scott storchway
you feel me like
so yeah like we just keep that way
that's it hey what up we gotta stop the
podcast real quick shout out to my
bookie man listen if you know anything
about me you know i like to gamble on
sports and i've been using my bookie for
so long go to mybookie.ag check it out
they're doing the my bookie double
deposit bonus this is how this works
you sign up you make a deposit you use
the promo code bootleg
and you're gonna get double your money
they're gonna match your deposit up to a
thousand dollars there's so much action
right now too the nba season is going
crazy maybe you could do a future right
who do you think is going to win the mvp
i don't know is it going to be honest is
it going to be devin booker is it gonna
be jokic
certainly ain't gonna be [ __ ]
russell westbrook
crazy odds that ain't gonna happen
that's just burning money with that
being said there's so many different
ways you can bet you can bet on your
daily games you can do the parlay i like
doing moneyline parlays i like to just
do three or four heavy favorites on that
nba schedule throw them all on one
ticket and and just try to hit you know
what i'm saying whatever you're into my
bookie you could bet on it anything go
to mybookie.ag they got the double
deposit bonus right now this is
important sign up for an account make a
deposit and they will match your deposit
double your money up to a thousand
dollars right now that's free money so
what are you doing use the promo code
bootleg when you sign up and you can
double your money get in on some of this
nba action man it's nba season all-star
games this weekend so much to i mean you
could bet on the three-point contest the
[ __ ] dunk contest whatever the
[ __ ] is going on who's gonna be the mvp
of the all-star game i don't know but
you could bet on it you could bet on
anything so make sure one more time
that's my bookie double your first
deposit up to a thousand dollars using
that promo code bootleg place your bets
what are we doing bet on anything
anytime anywhere with my bookie
[ __ ] let's go also shout out to
scott who's totally clean now he's got a
drug rehabby cones with steve lobel he's
doing some great things doing his thing
doing some great things and
he's just a great dude man great father
amazing amazing guy yeah um so
you say you're putting out more music in
the next two years than you've ever put
out is this like like do you already
have like a body of work to put together
are you still are you just constantly
recording like
nah constantly record well i'm gonna say
constantly i'm
very i don't just record just a record
it's an energy thing for me uh when i go
in the studio it's like
well i don't it depends on who i'm
working with like sometimes i work with
writers and i'm like we vibe like i'm
gonna go ahead and get this producer to
come in this producer come in and you
know we just go in and go crazy on some
you know on records because the vibe is
there if the vibes aren't there we just
cool we kick it whatever whatever so
i'm just finding out out who speaks my
language right now you know what i'm
saying who
how we can affect the culture together
there it is uh we were talking about the
wire a bit i got the wire shirt on when
you watched the wire did you ever
obviously be in from baltimore that show
was
probably came out
right right around the time you probably
started to like i don't remember the
year came out but i do remember like
when i first saw it i'm like yo this is
how realistic was it to the city like
because i i've heard a lot of people say
it was pretty spot-on
bro it was really on man baltimore is a
super raw city like you know what you
see is what you get you know what i mean
and if you go deeper into it you're
going to see you know it's like so many
different levels to it but like
it was definitely spot on you know um
from what i've experienced and what i've
seen in my life growing up
characters you know the
yeah it was in the city brothers looking
black it was all of the houses y'all see
like it's that a lot of the actors too
were just like
just they found them in baltimore like
snoop snoop was just in baltimore like
it was real man it was real it was one
of the best depictions of like if if you
shooting that side of it i think there's
a lot about baltimore that hasn't been
um shown though you know what i'm saying
from the
maybe the politics
the positive aspects the politics has
how it's grown
you know um i'm working on some projects
there right now too to like bridge music
um intellect
um
and mental health so yeah man it's gonna
be it's gonna be done but you still are
very much passionate about about making
sure you make your impact back home i am
i don't feel like i've done enough
enough to be honest right yeah so this
year next year like that was that's my
main focus outside is just like music
stuff and business stuff
how did you end up linking up with dre
london for people who don't know dre's a
[ __ ] mogul in the business but he
also you know i've known dre since 2014
yeah
but he works with post malone you know
he's yeah he manages post mode yeah he's
a great business dude like i've met dre
through um through my manager andy who
i've known for like 13 years we've been
homeless for years and he's been doing
his thing and you know um it was just a
conversation bro about music about
culture about
you know
about black music um
and
it was a no-brainer you know we just we
got the same vision when it comes to
like you know
how to impact the culture from an r b
standpoint
um and also me just
stepping back into my
my
independency but also doing it with
people who've done it on a certain level
because i've done it on a certain level
already so i have to work with people
who who understand that but who also
understands the boss part of it and and
the independent part of it that's just
you know it's a lot more responsibility
when you're independent artists as you
know
um
it's crazy because you know with what
you went through with your mom obviously
passing away i feel like
today there's a lot of kids who are
probably going through that
specific
ordeal um because of just the where
the world is with opiates and yeah and
fentanyl and like there's a lot of kids
who are dealing with their parents that
are addicted or dealing with losing
their parents to overdoses what would be
some advice you've lived it and
unfortunately obviously the absolute
worst thing came true for you but you
got through it you're here today what
would be some advice for someone
watching this who might be dealing with
someone who they love that's that's
going through something like that that
you could give them that maybe you know
you you lived it for them kinda
counseling
talk to somebody you know um
i wish i would have started sooner
i just actually started
mental health counseling
uh childhood trauma counseling
and i'm okay speaking about it because
um it's something that
you know when you're a strong person
and you're able to take the world on
your shoulders and and and perform under
pressure
oftentimes
you train yourself to to think that you
don't need
you know counseling you don't need to
talk about things that really bother you
like
it isn't until
something really triggers you that you
realize you ain't healed mm-hmm and i've
had those instances in my life and i've
ruined relationships because of those
types of things so i was like you know
what
let me do this for myself so that
you know i can have a family one day so
that i can be a father one day so that i
can be a better brother so i can be a
better friend like you know i'm saying
it it affects every part of your life as
you get over older because
those things don't just leave
you know for me it was definitely a
driving force
it taught me how to be numb it taught me
how to be
a perfectionist it taught me how to just
focus on work work work but it didn't
teach me how to heal so i had to take
that upon myself
um so i would say man mental health
is a real thing
and it needs to be you know if you know
and you're dealing with something if
something's bothering you you get
triggered and and you see yourself being
affected by this specific space in your
life then you got to talk about it you
got to get help for it yeah i think just
it's important for you to talk about
that because it lifts the stigma and i
think that the stigma started to get
lifted but like when you're somebody who
is the head of the household who so many
people depend on you're a leader in your
in your group your life it's like who do
you talk to right like who yeah who are
you gotta be somebody you trust you got
to be somebody you trust a trusted
source and you got to feel comfortable
but
definitely don't push it under the rug
you know you can't force someone to
stop using you can't force you know
someone to see how they hurting you
sometimes they don't know
because they're it's a disease you know
addiction is a disease man and it's like
it's
it's something that that
attacks people physically and
spiritually so it's a
it's a large karmic part of it that
comes with it's so much spiritually that
comes with it you know that if you're
if you you love somebody or you're close
to somebody that's experiencing that
it's important for you to also you know
get help for yourself while you're still
loving them through whatever they're
going through that's that's hey that's
right man yeah for sure you say you were
working on the video for this chris
brown record yes sir we getting all the
details together now you know
and andy they chopping it up getting
there getting it right how many uh
do you have the next thing already ready
or you just think i got it think so yeah
i think i got it okay so who have you
been you don't tell us who you got songs
with but just who you've been working
with like you've been in the studio
hanging out with me man of course my bro
a1 and then you know
uh me and london about to get in running
on the track so that's going to be a
movie
um
what's it been working with
d mile mm-hmm i'll just say those are at
the mile in london on the track like
those are the two producers i'm really
excited about like working with d mile
is just a
genius man he's just a musical genius
and he really loves music and he really
loves storytelling and he really loved
just like creating you know what i'm
saying
so he's somebody i always wanted to work
with and i feel like he just he he gets
music in a way
where
he's like a quincy where he could work
with you this artist and that artist and
give you all three wits specifically for
you you know what i'm saying in a space
where it's also classic and relevant
it's crazy because london has kind of
been the architect of like some of the r
b that we still kind of like oh this is
actual r b which is obviously summer
walker you know summer walkers yeah yeah
london is crazy or some of the um r b
acts that are newer that like inspire
you or that you're just like yeah this
is this is some like this is some [ __ ] i
can actually read the [ __ ] man lucky day
bro lucky lucky's fire
um
i would say lucky i would say
i like scissors a lot i don't know if
y'all still consider consider her new
but i think female artist wise her
opinion she's crazy
um i like queen nadja i got a crazy
record with her oh fire yeah she just
put out a new record that's crazy she
shout out to her she's shout out super
shout out to queen
um victoria monet she's been knowing
victoria for years she's an incredible
writer credible artist incredible
visionary when it comes to creativity
um who else
that's a few you know brent
yeah brethren not too far from you
blast is dope ty dolla is still one of
my favorite you know
prolific
got something crazy on his project
coming yeah ty's a prolific artist i
feel like we don't get tied into flowers
i'm like brother this ty is a [ __ ]
he's him he's him duncan he really he
ready one of them guys man
yeah shout out to ty so you got
something with on ty's new album yeah
yeah we got it crazy hopefully you can
make it on the project this is crazy
okay
uh it's gonna be a good year for r b for
sure hey we gotta stop the podcast man
real quick appreciate y'all for watching
uh really mean mean it subscribe like
leave a comment even if you're one of
those [ __ ] who leaves a comment
you're always interrupting the guest
because it's my [ __ ] podcast i don't
know i like to talk too
anyway
hey shout out to odd socks man they've
been our sponsor from day one we go hard
for odd socks always man
literally go hard for my wife and i go
hard for odd socks
in different and same kinds of ways you
know what i'm saying sometimes i go hard
in odd socks
they do make boxers
you feel me
anyway um listen they got the ill
licenses they got the breaking bad they
got the wwe they got mountain dew they
got [ __ ] swedish fish [ __ ]
kool-aid
uh
pez you know
cheech and chong what are you into the
odd socks basics are the boys though
that's my favorite you know you get
yourself a nice pair of just basics
they're comfy it's like walking on
clouds all right so you can save 20 off
if you go to oddssoxofficial.com
use the promo code bootleg kev that's
one word bootleg kev
all together
at checkout 20 off oddssocksofficial.com
go show some love and let's get back to
the interview
have you gotten in or hung out with post
malone at all obviously now that you
guys have dre is like a comedy yeah we
hung we definitely hung man we
definitely vibe different guy to kick it
with huh
man bud light
he's been did you play did you play beer
pong nah no
nah he's he being his own man he's a man
good energy bro no for sure he's the
best you man and he's still humble as
[ __ ] too very it's crazy you wouldn't
even be like oh you're the biggest
streaming artist in the world like but i
think that's what it is though man when
you vibrate on a certain level it's like
you're grateful for your accomplishment
but you're like literally living in the
moment bro it's the best feeling ever
that's like the greatest feeling ever is
being able to live in a moment and and
truly enjoy what you're creating and the
energy that you're cultivating and like
the people you like that's what it's
about for me now it's like so are we all
enjoying this this process because i
know we're gonna get to where we're
trying to go because we're focused and
we all great but are we enjoying it bro
are you enjoying you know what i'm
saying um
you say you don't watch a lot of tv what
are you doing in your spare time what
are your hobbies like if you're not
recording if you're not being an artist
what do you do man i want my dogs
uh
literal dogs i got two pits okay i'm
saying uh
traveling um
writing in my book uh
creating other business opportunities
i'm working on some things in the nft
space as well oh i just saw you posted
that nfc thing yeah but but not like on
some like quick money grab [ __ ] like
really on some i'm creating the projects
that are really passionate about
and then um
man business other business uh
adventures that i have like so i saw you
just posted uh one of the the monkey
things does it a trillionaire ape or
something [ __ ] i don't know apocalypse i
don't [ __ ] you know there's so many
different lotto i don't know what's
going on anymore i'm totally not a gift
to that it was a gift i'm not hip to
that space whatsoever yeah so i mean
it's you know what it's it's a if you're
if you like art
i like art like i collect art so i have
art now it's like physical but like
if you are into art and you're into
storytelling i think nfts can be a fun
investment you know if you want to just
do like quick flips and stuff you
definitely got to learn about it right
right right the end of storytelling and
you're into art i love do you throw the
oculus on and look at your nfts that way
nah i don't [ __ ] with oculus i have i
don't even have one oh you don't have
one pretty crazy yeah
the oculus is uh
yeah it's i could see you ever see the
movie ready player one
oh you gotta see it crazy it's the
oculus is i could see people getting
like sucked into that [ __ ] just like
never coming back
wow it's it's like oh you put that [ __ ]
on and you're just in another world like
virtual reality yeah but it's like you
could like you choose what kind of house
you live in like i mean i think i think
it's cool in moderation
in moderation that's the key because i
could see some some i don't know man
imagine like when they have call of duty
speaking bro like all right that's cool
like i think
stuff like instagram and some of these
other things are are just as bad bro if
you do it too much
you know what i'm saying like if you're
like it's so easy to spend so much time
and waste so much especially tick tock i
think tick tock is the one app that
people get sucked into just this swiping
that algorithm just feeds you [ __ ] it's
hard to put your phone down it's all
about balance man you know i think
right now we're at the end of the era
going into a new era you know what i'm
saying on so many different fronts you
know from
economically socially spiritually
energetically
you know right now
there are things being set in place
that's going to affect the next 30 40
years
so
i think
it's really weird because like as a
conscious person i'm looking at both
sides we're both
very much so
unaware as we are aware
of what's happening yeah so it's like
like
every day you're giving the red pill
with a blue pill and like
some days you take the blue pill some
days you take the red pill but at the
end of the day it all comes back down to
survival because that's the two things
that that our people are ran by i think
we're gonna look back like in survival
and like now and be like that was like a
really crazy time where the world was
changing and like we kind of knew it but
we also didn't really realize how much
it was changing exactly kind of like
when the internet first came out like 96
exactly it's like kind of like where we
are right now exactly and there's like
so many different ways like
you're like oh [ __ ] the world's changing
that means there's ways to make money
but then there's also ways to lose a lot
of [ __ ] money because if you don't
know what the [ __ ] you're doing in this
web 3.0 and this metaverse you might
[ __ ] end up there's been so many
scams and all kinds of craziness
it's a lot of stuff man you got to
connect with people who are really
passionate about what they're doing and
who really think about the the long term
thing but what i was trying to say is
that in general it's just like right now
is the time to invest in yourself the
most i feel like
that
means making sure that you spend time
out of your day
getting to know who you are and getting
to know what your strengths are what
your weaknesses are
maybe some gifts that you haven't
discovered you know
because you want to make sure that you
are a well-rounded person you know what
i'm saying there's it's unlimited what
you can do is unlimited so it's just a
matter of making sure you're a
well-rounded person or you know yourself
and you're not driven by the outside
world too much it's very hard this is so
easy it's also very hard to disconnect
from like
the garage seat yourself oh yeah yeah
for sure yeah i'm saying everyone's
always sure just working working working
working you know i feel like it's hard
to just disconnect and decompress like
but in order for you to actually it's i
don't know for me
in order for me to see
what i'm actually doing sometimes i got
to take a step back and look at
everything
like okay
three months from now i got to look at
the contacts the relationships the
people who i've invited into my whatever
i'm doing step back all right how is
that what because sometimes you could
just be moving and moving and moving
and then other things can be shifting
your trajectory of where you started or
where you were your original vision so
sometimes you got to step back and look
at the the progress right and give
yourself time to see the progress like
all right cool like
we still on the track you know what i'm
saying like i don't know i think it's
just because it's so easy to just
especially living out here is like you
know l.a it's the it's the always the
grind it's always
you know yes i ain't saying no grind you
gotta hustle no it's not like but it's a
little safe if somebody tell you don't
get no money get away from them
yeah cause we gotta survive for sure but
it's definitely like living in la is
like you're always on your toes here if
that makes sense it's like you know it's
like whatever you're doing it's like
okay i'm gonna go out to eat well [ __ ]
i'm in la so i can't just go out to eat
i gotta put some on i gotta you know
what i'm saying it's like there's so
much that goes in there just i mean i
think it's less
i feel like it was crazy like that
before depending on me like everything
had to be but now it's like i think
people have relaxed a little bit when it
comes to their ego within in certain
ways and also the pandemic checked a lot
of people's yes yeah a lot of people
were struggling this was like you know
yeah not real so you're yo let me love
you
you say uh
we just had a uh
artist named kyle on the show recently
you know super duper kyle yeah that song
i spy yeah so he uh
he was talking about how he has a song
called i spy which is about to be
diamond right and he's like damn well
he's like that's a i think he's eight
times platinum he's like uh this song
has changed my life
financially it's got me in a place where
like you know yeah it's so it's so big
that
i could kind of do what i want now
that's that's the gift and the curse but
but it's also like he's also the i spy
guy now you're not you're not the let me
love you guy but let me love you is one
of those songs that is so massive
between the remix the original it is one
of the most iconic r b songs of all
[ __ ] time yeah what is the curse part
of that for you because we know what the
gift is i think the the curse part of it
is easy it's just
you know
having that level of success again with
another record because i was so young
when it happened
and it's like i haven't had another
record that big even though i've had
other hits right
since that record you know and i think
that's the curse but i think every
artist has well not every artist some
artists got
18 20 number ones right but that's you
know if you're so lucky to have that and
have that type of system man god bless
you that's amazing you know but i think
that's the curse man just like
um
trying to trying to beat it out you know
what i'm saying trying to
argue
like like obviously every time i mean
that's that's that's a [ __ ] it's your
biggest record are you tired of
performing it after all these years
i feel like sometimes i'm gonna get
tired of performing it and then when i
perform it it feels like the first time
every time oh it's fire but it's because
of the fans man it's because of the
people it's because of them it's it's
like when you're on stage and you see
like
it's a connection bro cause you just
records they they they're like
they're like
time in the flesh bro like this this is
like i feel like recorded sound is time
in the flesh you literally
trap sound time into a sound and you're
able to relive it over and over and over
and over again so in some cases yes it
could feel
as if
you're not moving forward
but
when you see a record transcends so many
generations
and you see
like
i see tick tocks of like babies or like
toddlers singing let me love you i'm
just like bro today yeah of course
such a blessing man it's
yeah um
obviously the first record i had ever
heard of yours was just a friend which
uh sampled bismarck bismarck he recently
passed away um rest in peace man yeah as
a young kid like what was it like you
know connecting with biz sampling his
record
i mean did you know much about biz
before he ended up cutting that record
like what was what was he like as a dude
shout out to
warren campbell my brother hell lilly
man biz
he really i feel like
anybody who meet him or feel like he
liked their uncle like
he was very much so expressive very
thoughtful
he didn't hold his tongue
you know i'm saying if he saw something
he had it
always hit me to check up on me like
even if when you talk for years i see
him out at an event it was always love
um
when i was on tour last saw the
millennial toy he came out at my
baltimore show oh dope he surprised me
and pulled up like
man this is a good dude good dude indeed
yeah good dude all right so we got more
music coming this year
definitely more music um
film stuff as well you know
a lot of great yeah well i don't know if
i'm gonna put that out this year man i'm
really taking my time with it but it's
definitely coming for sure but tour
um just more more sauce man what's the
tour
talk about the tour what what are you
what are you doing with the tour well
we're planning it you know we're
planning it for like probably later this
year is it gonna be you and like some
other people like hopefully yeah that's
the plan to put a nice package together
like you know that makes sense so
i just put it out there like you know
what i'm saying so it's like tour
um
more music and just more me man more
more mario for the fans for the people
like
just you know
putting the stamp on r b where i need to
be and continue to do carry my carry my
legacy